when I score I must spin the ball
[Applause]
[Music]
that was excellent I'm a little worried
now I'm Carlos by the way yeah I'll be
getting you to do the exact same thing
we just did I hope so
no one actually work with a lot of
artists who don't dance at first and
then eventually we build their
confidence to be performers on stage
[Applause]
he's a super strong guy as we know the
big question is how stiff is he how
groovy easy we're gonna step to the left
go one two one two one two
what's the beginner I don't know where
legs step with feet all right exactly
what we did in the first a terrible
memory I saw when he came in that he was
a little apprehensive about it I'm gonna
try to get him to relax build his
confidence and I think that will shine
through the performance pretty when I'm
warm all right and it's gonna get faster
there we go slide nice work through it
to top top if you start strong and
finish strong I need your neck right
let's go I'll stay here let's go ha all
right let's increase the speed nice nice
here we go let's go breathe breathe
breathe detail detail detail detail go
one and two beautiful nice here we go
five and six keep going ha ha ha so the
most important thing in choreography
like these are the details right there
boom you make it work now cross turn
down I'm impressed
my first go I'm impressed
[Applause]
I'm very excited I think it is really
amazing and it actually helped me
realize how fast you can build so much
confidence anything you could just do
some of my movies when it scores a
touchdown
[Music]
[Applause]
preciate you go thank you you want to go
one more time no yeah I'll get back to
work